- When I was little, I
had to get a real woman,
a real girl, and we
would go to the woods,
and I would try and
take her top off.
For real.
(slow dubstep music)
(cheering)
- So here's the
story with the show.
Really simple, just a
bunch of funny people
who are all telling
true stories.
I'm really excited
to have this guy,
he's one of the
funniest men in America,
Mr. Tom Papa, everybody,
let him hear it.
- I have a lot of
women in my life.
I've always had a lot
of women in my life.
I was raised with girls,
my mom was a girl,
my grandmother was a girl,
I married a girl,
and now I've made my own girls.
I have my own girls,
that I've made.
Yeah, I made them.
And people always ask me things,
like do you think they'll
end up working in a huh?
And yeah, maybe.
(audience laughing)
I mean they're little now.
All I can go by is
their gymnastic moves,
and they got that covered.
They're good with that.
(audience laughing)
Then it's just gonna
come down to desire.
How badly do they want it?
They can make their
dreams come true.
People always ask me, like,
are you worried about them now?
Like, are you
worried about kids?
I can't believe,
like with phones,
are you worried that these
kids have these phones?
I mean, I would hate raising
children now with these phones.
Aren't you terrified of
what they're going to do
with these phones?
No.
I'm not worried
about them at all.
They're gonna handle it.
They'll be fine.
I'm not worried about what
it's gonna do to them.
I'm worried about
what it's doing to me.
It's making me into a
nosy, boarish douchebag.
I am spying on my own creatures.
I made these people,
and I'm spying on them.
It's so douchey.
It's such an awful way to live.
I don't care what they do.
Why am I invading and
spying on what, you know...
Back off.
You care that your son
is on boobs.com, really?
Really?
You're little guy's in there,
boobs, big boobs, dot cah.
(audience laughing)
Is that really bad?
When I was little, I had to
get a real woman, a real girl,
and we would go to the woods,
and I would try and
take her top off.
For real.
(audience laughing)
Because there was
no dot anything.
And we would just
do it until finally
she would take her top off,
and she was happy
and I was happy,
and our parents
didn't know about it.
(audience laughing)
They weren't spying
through our shit.
They weren't going
through my texts.
They weren't doing any of that.
So who cares?
Just back off.
Let them do what
they're gonna do.
This is the way I've
always wanted to do it.
You have tools, it's a tool.
They have a tool.
This is their tool to get laid.
Everyone has a
tool in their era.
This is their tool.
You wanna get laid, you
gotta learn to use this tool.
(audience laughing)
I needed a car.
I needed a goddamn car.
I needed to get in a
car and drive around
and look for women.
That was my tool.
And I knew that at a young age,
and I bought a car two years
before I was able to drive.
(audience laughing)
I busted my ass.
I went out and bused tables
in a shitty little restaurant
called The Orchards
in a Hilton Hotel.
I would just put
on a green bowtie
and I would walk at four
o'clock in the morning
down to the school, wait
for my friend to pick me up
because he had a car already,
and I would just sit
there and shiver,
and he would come
and pick me up,
and he was the king.
He was the king.
But I bided my
time, because I knew
you're not gonna be
the king for long.
I might be in a
green bowtie now,
but I will be king
in two goddamn years.
(audience laughing)
And I just kept working.
I didn't get respect.
I got my ass kicked.
I was just sitting
there with a bowtie.
People would just be
like, get over here.
More water, boy.
More rolls, boy.
And I would just lick them
and put them in the basket.
(audience laughing)
I was like yeah, I may
have a green bowtie,
but I'm a badass underneath it.
(audience laughing)
And I saved up, and I got $1600.
$1600.
And I called my uncle, Uncle
Al, he ran a junk yard,
and we called him Uncle
Al, all the kids' pal,
because he always had weed.
Always had a lot of weed.
(audience laughing)
Yeah, still does, still does.
And he's still our pal.
And I said Uncle
Al, I got $1600.
He said I got a car for you.
I got a car for you.
A used 1982 Toyota Corolla.
I said that sounds
great, what color is it?
He said baby shit orange.
(audience laughing)
Sold, I'll take it.
And I put it in my garage,
and I couldn't drive
it for two years.
I'd just pet it, I would
pet it, and talk to it,
and just wait for the day
when I was able to go out
and find girls.
And when I turned 17,
it was time to hunt.
It was like a hunting dog.
I would just give it a scent.
I found a scrunchie in the park,
smell it boy, smell it.
(barking like a dog)
And we'd cruise around.
And it worked, we got girls.
We got girls in
baby shit orange.
That was how powerful
having a car was.
And that's when I met Heidi,
I met this beautiful girl.
She became my girlfriend,
she was gorgeous.
She was six feet tall.
Six feet tall.
No, no.
It wasn't the big scary
goonish six feet tall.
(audience laughing)
It wasn't like "hey Tom.
I don't think I can fit
in baby shit orange."
No, this was like long legs,
athletic, gorgeous girl,
and we would just, that was it,
we just got in baby shit
orange, we went everywhere.
To the beach, to the mountains,
just having sex
everywhere we went.
We were like sexual athletes.
Just in between those
giant long legs,
and my parents didn't
know shit about it,
because they couldn't
go through my texts,
because it didn't exist.
It didn't exist.
I learned everything from her.
I learned how to
please a woman orally
from because you're 17, stamina.
They don't make a drug
that could make me
that strong right now.
They don't, it does not exist.
If you're 17, you are
like, you're like a lion,
you're just so...
But you're not good.
You're not good.
(audience laughing)
It's not gonna last long.
It's gonna be blah!
And just, it's gonna be over.
And that's where you learn to
please a woman another way.
And if you have a man in your
life that pleases you orally,
it's not because
he cares about you.
It's because he
doesn't last very long.
(audience laughing)
He needs different skills.
And we never caught.
We never got caught, we just,
getting laid for years.
I would literally drive
my car home for curfew,
go to bed, say
goodnight to everyone,
wait for them to sleep,
and around midnight,
I'd open my window, I'd
go out on the garage roof,
I would hang on the gutter,
I'd hang my little
legs down until I felt
the banister below me,
then I'd get on that.
All those moves took like a
half hour, each one of them.
I was just, do I hear anything?
Do I hear anything?
And then drop.
And then I'd push baby shit
orange into the street,
and we would just
cruise down, no,
and then pop it into gear, wing.
Go up to Heidi's house,
park in her bushes,
and she lived like way down here
and her parents
were way up there,
and I would just
climb in her window,
and we'd have sex
every single night.
And baby shit orange just
stood there, waiting for me.
And would go back,
and I'd climb back in,
and every night, I never got
caught, never got caught.
Until one night, one night,
in the middle of
these long legs,
I'm doing what I was taught
to do in an oral manner,
(audience laughing)
and the door opened,
the door opened,
and the light just shone on
my 17 year old white ass.
It was her father.
And this is what he says.
"Tom, it's time to go home now."
(audience laughing)
That was it, and
closed the door.
And closed the, I
was freaked out.
I'm like what do I do?
Do I just put my clothes on
and go out the front door?
He knows I'm here.
Do I have to climb
out the window?
I think I'm...
I'll go out the
window, he's probably,
he acted so cool.
I'm like he probably has
an ax in the hallway.
Let me just go out the window.
So I went out the window,
and I loved this girl,
she was my girlfriend, so I
had to come back the next day
and confront the
father and apologize,
because I loved her, I
wanted to be with her.
And I actually got in
my car, it was a Sunday,
and I drove up to her
house to apologize
to the father this girl.
I had such stronger
character at 17
than I have right now.
If that happened right now,
I'd never see this girl again.
I would just get in baby shit
orange and just go, leave,
to another state.
But I was like no,
I'm gonna do it,
I'm gonna sit down, I'm
just gonna apologize.
And I remember he
was watching tennis.
He was watching tennis.
He didn't even look up.
I was like, man, I'm
really really sorry.
I didn't mean to be in,
I know it was late.
I shouldn't have been in here.
Voice all cracking.
I didn't say exactly
what I was doing,
because I didn't
know what he saw.
I don't wanna be like, I
really shouldn't have been
going down on her, but
I don't last that long.
(audience laughing)
So I just went with
the, it's late,
I'm so sorry, it
was really late.
And this is what he says.
He goes, whoa, you kids,
and kept watching tennis.
(audience laughing)
I was like, this is
the greatest man alive.
Forget Gandhi, this
guy is at peace.
This guy is centered,
this guy is just one
with the universe.
I'm like, I'm gonna be this guy.
When I get older, this is the
father that I'm going to be.
I'm gonna be so
chill and so zen,
I'm gonna be exactly
like this guy,
because he didn't kill me.
And I'm gonna be this guy.
And I...
Fast forward, I've
made my own people.
I've made my own people.
I have a daughter, and
my wife just tells me...
- [Audience Member] Woo!
- Thank you.
And my wife tells me,
just sitting there
chopping vegetables,
just lets it be known,
just kind of out of
the side of her mouth,
just like it's nothing,
you know there's a boy
texting your daughter.
- [Audience Member] Woo.
- Woo.
That would've been
the zen response.
Woo.
But I didn't.
I just yelled out, get
me her fucking phone.
(audience laughing)
(applauding)
No zen, no nothing.
I don't even use, I don't
curse a lot in my life ever,
and now in front of my
little daughter and cats
and everybody else,
I just blurt out,
in my own kitchen,
get me her fucking phone.
And this is how awful,
this is why I feel
so nosy and shitty.
I get her phone, and I'm like
all right, I'm gonna bleah,
let's see what this
is about, where is it?
I know her code, I
can use this, blah.
Oh here he is.
Here he is, the little shitbird.
Let's see what he's
doing with our daughter.
First text is like, what are
you gonna be for Halloween?
I'm thinking of Batman, hahaha.
She's like oh, I might
be Snow White, LOL,
rainbow rainbow unicorn.
(audience laughing)
What's you're favorite candy?
Kit Kat bars.
Me too.
Pizza pizza.
Nyah.
Little thing dancing, I
can't wait for the parade,
me either, honk honk honk,
hearts hearts hearts,
smiley face, nyah.
(audience laughing)
What a piece of shit I am.
Total piece of shit.
(applauding)
So I'm off.
I'm not gonna go through
her phone anymore.
I will take a drill and
bolt her window shut,
(audience laughing)
but I'm gonna stay
off her phone.
Thank you guys so much.
(dubstep music)